thank you for coming for my talk
um so first of all I always said this is
the most important slides because I got
the link to the to the whole slide deck
and also there's like all my you know
social media like presence you can like
kind of if you have questions for
example tomorrow when you wake up you
have a question you can still DM me on
Twitter Mastodon is the same handle but
I don't check as frequently as Twitter
sadly but um I we track both basically
um so
um
we are going to profile our data science
work on how it's going to work I'm gonna
show you but first of all
um so this is me I'm Chuck I work for
Anaconda I used to be a data scientist
but now I am developer Advocate at
Anaconda I love open source project uh
also like this morning you have heard uh
you know that we have to support
non-focused projects so please talk to
them in the booth um also I help
organize a lot of conference because
again I love the community so
um so who have been there who have seen
this era memory error yes we have all
been there you know every time we saw
that it's like kind of you know it's
almost as bad as seeing the blue screen
of that right it's like oh my God I have
to run it again oh so
um yeah that's why we have to do memory
profiling and what is memory profiling
so before I really show you how it can
be done um you may of course those of
you who got really good eyesight you may
also see that I have a tab open there's
a Jupiter notebook but I'm going to show
you after
um before that I want to talk about what
is profiling for some of you who haven't
heard about the term before in software
engineering
um we do profiling which is actually
investigating our program's behavior
um so usually it's kind of something
that we kind of like inspect your
program when it's being execute so
that's why I sometimes also call like
Dynamic analysis because it's actually
what is really happening it's not
because of your code you kind of like
analyze it because of how you write your
code and stuff but it's what is actually
being executed and
um so we have tools to do that we have
tools to inspect or monitor your code
when it's got executed uh it's called
profiler
um so there are actually many many
different type of profiling you may
heard of like C profiler or this
different thing that people use
um but today we're going to focus on
memory profiling so uh like I said
before profiling we're monitoring our
code and for memory profiling especially
we are looking at how memory is being
used when we execute our program so it's
about memory allocation one thing that's
always been talked about is the garbage
collection because when some memories
that has been used and it's not needed
anymore is supposed to be free and like
get rid of the stuff you stole there
before is well that's scavish and you
have to collect them so you free up the
space
um but you know it's not always going to
happen perfectly that's why it's always
talk about because things may go wrong
and we really want to get it done right
um so when the program get executed over
time we want to make sure that all the
memory is being used efficiently there's
you know you're not going to get that
memory error again so that's why we we
won't investigate we want to see what's
going on
um so why we need a memory profile
especially I think there's something
that has been overlooked when doing data
science work you know we we're all like
kind of you know data scientists we all
care about the statistic about like
getting all these analysis telling the
story from the data but sometimes we
forgot that we are also using the
computer and we should actually think
about how the computer computer is doing
is it going to surface perfectly or is
it kind of having some hiccup somewhere
in your code so
um so for example data science work you
may have done that before you load the
super big you know data said you we have
to handle a lot of data sometimes we run
off memory very easily especially on
older machines nowadays you know like
machine or cluster whatever you use on
the cloud are very powerful you can
always spin up a bigger one but you may
be paying more if you're spinning up a
bigger cluster so you may as well see if
your code is you know doing the proper
thing and optimizing all your memories
um so by them apps you know we all love
python pipe it's very easy to use but
um but python because it's so user
friendly sometimes like we kind of
obstruct and didn't look at like at a
low level is our main memory being
managed properly we can't really have
the transparency to see it so um so a
lot of times you know when we're not
careful we get that memory error or even
worse because we are doing scientific
work a lot of the uh tools the libraries
that we're using actually have a lot of
external plugins that's probably not you
know within you know or written in
python or something that's written in
some other languages
so sometimes you know we may get
something that oh it takes forever to
run but I don't know why at the end of
the day you don't have the patient you
have to cure it it may be because
actually you're running out of memory
but because of the communication between
the plugin and Python and then somehow
it doesn't get raised the the air
doesn't get raised so just waiting there
forever for nothing so it's not good
so uh we need to know what's going on so
before you kind of you know deploy your
work scouting it up you have to do our
profiling
um so a lot of terms getting involved
when we kind of starting to do profiling
you may see them online all the time and
stack Overflow whatever when you ask a
question people talk about this all the
time
um hip stack memory what are they
um so I am trying to like so this is
what I found out I was trying to do a
comparison so hit memory usually it
means that it's just like a big kind of
bubbles or sea of variables like they're
Global variables they can be stored
anywhere there's no structure to it so
that's why you need a reference
otherwise it's kind of you know lost in
the abyss and then you kind of don't
know where they are and you don't know
that they are not needed anymore and you
forgot to collect them which is the
garbage collection so these need to be
free
um if you if you know if a tool or a
program that's like do it properly then
all these garbage will be collected and
free up the memory so you can do more
stuff
um or if you kind of for example again
something happened and you have no
patient to wait for the program to
finish and you killed it then well it
will be free because your process got
terminated it's basically done by the
operation system so it's like something
that is not about your program it's
about you know you killed everything so
they all go free up
um on the other hand there's like stat
memory stack memory usually is for local
variables so that's why local variables
when it's outside of the scope you can't
access those variables because they are
still in Step memory and you know they
will be free when your function returns
so outside of your function is gone you
don't have access to it anymore but
those like uh you know there's no
problem of like you know forget to
collage the carpet with garbage because
you know they are in order so when once
your function is done like all of them
will be erased there's less problem of
these kind of you know leakage of memory
so another thing that could talk about
all the time is the Reston set and
virtual memory wow it's so fancy these
terms I love it so residents what is it
it's a residence means that how much is
actually used on your computer RAM so
but sometimes it's like something that
you know first how you make compare like
all physical universals or something
that's actually used
um because nowadays computers are very
smart if you are not doing something get
for example you haven't loaded in a CSV
yet you don't have to hold up that kind
of space you know
um or sometimes even like more low level
your computer will swap all this memory
around when it's not being used is going
to be storing something else before it
got to be used so
um so basically it's just making more
efficient so sometimes you can run a
program that actually require more
memory than actually the ram you have on
your computer because of this like
resident and virtual memory thing
because things got swapped around so
residents about like what is actually
being used at the moment
virtual memory is the whole process how
much memory is needed for the whole
process to be finished so that like
sometimes it like I said maybe bigger
than what you actually have because
things got swapped around and stuff so
that's why sometimes looking at it you
have to bear in mind that
you know what you are really using what
you really needed so for example uh
resident memory how much it's using you
can actually like got a really reliable
estimate of whether you're running out
or not whether virtual you know you may
compare you know program which one use
more memory at the end of the day but
you know it may be not reflecting how
much memory you're actually using at any
certain point of time
so to make it more complicated different
operating system may be different as
well so I'm just giving a general idea
here so uh well what actually is
happening really depends on your
computer so it's very difficult to
explain everything so I'm just giving an
Overlook at this point
um so how does python do all these
complicated things you know python can
be installing my machine in your machine
on different operating system so python
actually did a pretty good job of making
things work on different operation
systems with the memories so I hope it's
not too small I don't know why it
becomes so small but anyway
um so
so python actually store objects with a
very very interesting mechanism so first
of all it will have a private Heap so
I'll explain more in detail so there's
like things called Arena and then all
these python objects actually blocks you
can imagine as a lack of blocks that
they kind of like fill up this Arena
um so in Python we have a so you may
heard this name before Primal log which
is actually the python like memory
manager that's built in
um it is kind of like the higher level
kind of things and then below it there's
actually other like C apis there's like
you know so complicated that I don't
even understand so I won't explain that
to you so it's like Pi mem Royal Mail
log that kind of thing so I won't look
at the C code because I I'm not very
good at c
um so and then after that it would
actually talk to your uh you know your
machines management system so virtual
memory management manager so those are
actually like OS dependent so
um
so the so different type of python
object actually they would have a
different size
for example so this help heimelot work
so uh actually primer lock is designed
for small objects so the maximum size of
the mo the objects that can work with
primer log is 512 bytes so
a defined amount of size it can be
smaller can be bigger so that's the the
maximum size of the block for your
python object
so all this block like I said they are
fueling up this Arena so everything is
kind of managed like block by block so
it's very organized way of doing it uh
Advantage is you know very easy to
implement very quick you know to access
and stuff but but may not be the most
optimized things to do and also if it's
bigger than 512 bytes then it will fall
back into using other more complicated
things like the pi mem Royal Mail log or
the other things
um so also the size is kind of like
needs to be a multiple you know of age
or it's from age to five 512 so you know
because they are blocks and they can
only like be stacking you know kind of
in units
so
that's all the technical details
um but we want to know how we can
actually use it right how are we going
to do it when we are using our Jupiter
notebook doing some data science work
what are we gonna do so I found a tool
that actually is uh is can do the memory
profiling and it will work in your
Jupiter notebook so this is memory
um so this I'm not involved in this
project and so I'm just telling you
because it works with Jupiter notebook
and let's see how it works so I have
this code here I can also put the link
for this slides and all this code
in this code later so don't worry about
it if you want to try it at home you can
you know download the code or something
um so I'm going to show you the first
one
which is explaining some kind of basic
so when you're using it how I'm going to
look at it have you know using is very
easy but how to interpret it is a little
bit you know require a little bit of
knowledge so
um like I said this Tool Work will ship
is a notebook so there's actually a
plugin that you could use so uh you know
we have all used this percentage magic
before just like for example net polip
you have used the percentage magic so
it's kind of like that so you're loading
the extension of course you have to have
memory installed it's quite a while I
don't know why maybe I'm running off
memory
so
yeah uh why please
uh okay I'll just run the cell and
hopefully something will happen
yeah why is taking so long I think maybe
I'm
oh yeah it's starting now yeah it's very
very slow usually it's not that slow I
think I opened too many tabs like you
you'll see at the bottom you see
I'm trying to demonstrate what happened
when you run out of memory okay so
um no I'm just joking so this is an
example that they show in their official
documentation so it's kind of showing
you how it looks like when you use this
percentage magic and to get a frame
graph so what is a frame graph a frame
graph for people who like developers who
have done this kind of like profiling
work before of course they're not you
know they're familiar with it that's not
new for them but for data scientists it
may be something very new and this is
yeah I'm assuming in too much but don't
worry I have a solution for that
um but anyway look at this beautiful
frame graph we have um everything is
block so uh you can see that actually
for each function so I'm looking at it
like kind of top down you can revert it
like you can flip it over if you want
but what I'm doing it here is to um
showing you that for example this if
this function is calling something
that's kind of like it's showing below
that so for the the most bottom one for
example this one is actually the deepest
core if you look at this right this is a
very you know kind of
um you know iterated not iterated but
like layered on kind of structure you
can see the last call are C and D so
it's the a times n which is very silly
but it's a demonstration so I said these
are c and d right so they are the
deepest core because you know everybody
is calling them layer by layer
that's how it would look like in a frame
graph so if you want to look at what is
the deepest score look at the bottom of
it right
or you can flip it around I forgot how
to oh you can flip it around like this
this is more like you know a tower if
you can imagine so the other is like a
well this is like a tower
um so
to look at something more complicated
let's run this example okay so here
um you see that this is a little bit
irregular because now we are doing
things that are more complicated there
are different things not just a times n
all the time but sometimes they're
different sizes so that's obviously that
we they will be using different amounts
of memory that's why it's like kind of
irregular in this example so uh we call
this uh like this Edge that has nothing
on on well let's inverted because the
term makes more sense if we inverted it
so this we call it a roof because
there's nothing on top of it right
there's the deepest layer if it's got
inverted so
um we want to look at those roofs reason
being that roofs kind of show you what
is occupying the memory for example if
you see that for example this one so
this is actually the core if you believe
me right it's kind of too big but it's
it's actually F so f is calling G so
basically f is doing nothing except
calling G so but G is doing something
right so you can see here that this is G
this is f so G is sitting perfectly same
size on top of f because
how much memory f is using is how much
memory G is using right so you know it's
just doing nothing but calling G
function so that's why it's this
so uh when you look at this this way
then there's nothing for you to optimize
in F because well if you can optimize G
it basically optimize F right but for uh
and counter example is something like
this one so this one so if you believe
me because the the box is too big it's
actually d so D is doing a bunch of
things so you can see D here
it will have other functions as a roof
for example this one I delete yeah this
one is e and this one is f so E and F is
another box to sit on top of uh D so
they are not the roof of D because
there's something on top right but D
actually got its own roof here this
small Edge is this roof so it means that
you can actually optimize D if you can
optimize D in some way that get rid of
this roof then it will be more efficient
then it's just up to E and F
so that's why it's very important to
final this roof and to see where you can
improve
um or optimize your code for example you
write a bunch of things and then you see
that oh actually you got a big roof
somewhere then maybe I can improve that
a little bit how change things a little
bit and see if that could improve things
it's very abstract isn't it so let's
look at something more practical
so I have another thing that I love ice
cream by the way so I always use the ice
cream as an example so I'm going to run
a bunch of cell because it takes a while
because of my fault I'm so sorry
um so let's look at the coke first while
it's running so I'm doing something you
know I have some CSV which is about Ice
Cream review and products I'm going to
load them in using pandas and I'm just
going to run this bunch of things it's
just pandas nothing very interesting and
look at this here
oh it's done okay so you can see it's
just a pandas data frame we're all
familiar with it so this is something
that maybe something similar to what you
do day day to day you know cleaning up
the data for example this one uh for
example I want to get a year yearly stat
right because uh you know all this
review
um they are very detailed but they are
also like a different date I want to
congregate them in two different years
so I can see how each ice cream is doing
where they get more popular this year
less popular this year I want to have a
look at that so
um what I'm going to do is the most you
know straightforward thing is that
because this is the string I haven't
showed the D type here but if you show
the D type this is a string so I can
actually cop out the first four letters
they will be actually the year right so
I'm gonna oh okay good goodbye using
that so that's what I'm doing here
right
um but there's another way to do it is
how about I do it properly in quotation
convert that string into a date and then
I just get the year of it right so this
is the second way of doing it so I have
two versions of doing the same thing
and I'm going to you know so this is
doing the other join and stuff you know
I hope you are familiar with it because
you're all doing data science work so um
yeah so it's just
yeah you know doing a bunch of like
group by and enjoying together
so this is the first version that is
just uh copying the first four letters
of the string so let's see how
it performs so you can see the frame
graph here oops I think it's yeah it's
this way it's very complicated right so
because like panda is doing a lot of
complicated things that we are too
scared to look at
but you can see that we have this this
thing right this thing we know because
it's calling get yes that
this is using the first method which is
getting the first four letters of the
string
and I want to compare to the version 2
which is converting it into a date so
how does it how does it different I'm
doing same thing I can have a look in
comparison and
so this is here this one so you may see
that oh my God this is like how can you
look at this is well if you really don't
want to look at it one thing good about
it is that all the results actually are
saved as an HTML file so for example
this one if I look at it it's saved to
so t m p a something something so can I
find it
yeah this one is actually the same frame
graph it's in a HTML file so this is
easier to see I hope um yep so it's
easier to see
so yeah this one is the one that I get
it you know convert into date and then
it's a year
so you can see compare these two so this
actually you know um East Coast saying
how much is still too big but so sorry
let me zoom out a little bit to see if
it's better so I can see no it's not
revert it and
yeah the one thing I don't like about
this like because it's you know it's too
long I really can't see much and then I
can't I can't really zoom in and out to
to have a good better look
you can see I want to compare this one
okay what I can do is to run it again
because sometimes the the order will be
swapped if I run it again
yeah now it's like kind of in a hacking
hacky category right so okay now you can
see that it's using 3.2 megabytes so
um
MIB I don't think it's megabyte it's not
using that much but anyway 3.2 right
remember this and then we compare it to
the first one
which is this one here is your one Pawn
1.2 so oh actually version one is better
I've just caught the first four letters
and it's like actually if I convert it
into a python data object it's actually
using more memory so now you know which
one you should do if you don't care
about doing it properly using the date
object if you just want to quickly do a
group by you know what to do it's very
you know quick
um to to just uh so my instinct was
right so this is what I would normally
do just to crop the four first of all
letter and then do a group by like very
quickly and this is actually the more
efficient if in memory perspective more
efficient way of doing it so
now you know and you have proven that oh
after years of data science experience
I'm actually doing it more efficiently
yeah so
um yeah so this is just basically how
you do it um of course you know it's a
bit you know difficult at the beginning
it's a bit scary you know so many calls
and stuff but
um I hope you can try doing it
um it's you know it may help you to
solve some mystery sometimes you know
why is using up so much memory because
you know sometimes you're doing some
kind of you know prove a table or you
know joining different data frames and
then why it's got frozen up this may be
why and you you may investigate and
somehow somehow you may be able to
squeeze you know your CSV into a small
enough memory to be working in memory
instead of you know spinning up a bigger
customer it costs more money so you can
tell your company I save money right so
this is quite good so I think that's all
I have to say about memory profiling the
last thing I want to tell you is about
Euro python which is uh you know a
conference that I've been help
organizing in the past few years and
it's this year is going to be in July
and it's going to be amazing in Prague
and tomorrow I hope someone's going to
tell you more in the lighting talk I
hope so um or if you have any questions
talk to me I have Anaconda pen if you
talk to me about Anaconda I'll give you
some slack
um so that's it um thank you so much is
there any questions on Slide
thank you so much for a very memorable
talk I'm so sorry I had to
um
there are actually three questions up
for now five they're currently coming in
but maybe we can already get started
with one
um
can memory show runtimes as well on the
x-axis do you know that I'm on the X so
the x-axis you mean this one right
there you can see that if you run it the
second time you know the order will be
flipped so they are not actually the
order of that it has been executed it's
just like uh if if a function is calling
another function so that's the order of
execution is on the y-axis no on the
x-axis so
um yeah the x-axis doesn't mean too much
it's just for comparing how much each
process is causing you know if you have
a longer X you know the box if the box
is longer it means that it's using more
memory so that that's the x-axis the
y-axis is like actually the calling
order
then the next question would be how does
this work with parallel implementations
is there a fancy
yeah I mean uh it actually you can I
think there's like a thing you can flip
to look at the pillow as well if I
remember correctly then we have a look
at one of the things the
yeah oh I remember no actually there's
some settings that you could allowed uh
so if you look at the documentation
right memory memory documentation
um they will show you that actually
there are some like uh parameters that
you can add to to this percentage magic
to turn on like parallelization or these
other things that you could you know um
because I know there are a lot of data
science tools that actually is using a
lot of optimization to do maybe parallel
or like you know pre-compiled stuff so
those parameters may help you to
investigate more so yeah
is memory the most commonly used memory
profiler and what are other good
Solutions yeah
yeah I look
[Music]
Ed if you're the new book they just you
know because when I get interested I've
I've heard like one of the co-developer
announced that memory now has a Jupiter
notebook plugin so of course there are
other tools that can do the same thing
but it may not be as easy to use on your
Jupiter notebook as memory there are
also other profilers as well which like
not just looking at memory but also like
maybe the speed other performances but
um you know so but I I kind of like
membrane because it worked with juvenile
Brook
um is there a way to process memory
output data non-visually somebody wants
to export it to a data frame
then you can export the report as well
now you can see that like all these
frame graph is generated as an HTML but
there's other format that you can kind
of output all the results
um related to getting things a little
bit
less cluttered is there a way to only
say profile my code and ignore the
underlying functionalities ah there
you can see this like oh hi hi this like
system frame but it doesn't it helps a
little bit but it doesn't help much
because again like a lot of them are not
considered a system frames it's just
pandas doing Panther things so so yeah
it helps a little bit but not like
perfectly I know what you mean like oh
what if you just showed the code that
I'm explicitly written here right
unfortunately is not going to be but if
you check this that will hide some of
the stuff that's like even more
complicated than the pandas internal so
yeah
I guess we have time for one last short
question
do you know if there's a spider plug in
for memory spider oh my God I
have to confess I haven't used spider
for a long time
I don't know
sorry about that
all that okay thank you so much
yes thank you